happened Monday reject nation I'm Craig
Alba hi I'm John Humphrey
we're gonna watch scary stories to tell
in the dark v/o the show trailer I'm
looking forward checking this out John
grew up on scary stories to town the
dark yeah I did not before we go into
that I wanted to say I am grateful for
everyone who has followed us at our
patreon page over there we do weekly q
and A's as well as TV show reactions
stream along for many shows that
includes my hero academia Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood one punch man
attack on Titan I literally just shot at
the last episode for attack on Titan and
eyes are a little red that was a tear
jerker that one supernatural Gotham
haunting of Hill House and Cobra Kai
season two and several of those shows
have reaction highlights included those
are attack on Titan one punch man Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood and
supernatural he does music video
reactions occasionally anywho let's see
what's going on here
mmm-hmm some people believe if we repeat
stories often enough
they become real attraction law of
attraction they make us who we are
[Music]
that can be scary do you want to see a
haunted house okay sorry we gonna I knew
line
scary stories tell you story
let's go
Tommy's missing Tommy's name was in the
book there's no way it's actually
connected happens in the exactly
[Music]
stories write themselves alive oh no
don't die doggy
[Music]
Oh Alex I love that trailer yeah I loved
it more than the last one I think the
last one maybe honed in a little better
on my creep factor but this one actually
gave me a sense of what the movies gonna
be well yeah the first one made me kind
of wonder a little bit whereas this yeah
makes me sort of go I can see how this
would totally work as a movie yeah this
concept of telling stories that come
true
I love it because one thing I was
curious about was how are they gonna be
able to tell a wide variety of creatures
tales and not have a feel bombarded is
it going to be like an anthology kind of
deal it's not like final destination
it's just kinda semi and constant
reminding me of it in terms of death is
coming for this specific person that has
been named or their next on the list and
that and with this like book of the
characters they're in this story
so essentially death is coming for them
next I'm loving the whole aesthetic to
it I think the kids dynamic kids in
peril is a great horror thing that's
coming around a lot these days
but these kids look like a lot of fun
they look like they're having damn I
look like I have great chemistry I think
one looks really natural it doesn't look
like they're trying to replicate or ape
the losers Club exactly you know it look
they feel like a natural group of small
town high school friends and I like that
like the first trailer reminded me of
like a darker a bit more aggressive
version of goosebumps and I like well I
still kind of get those vibes because
there's a definite similarity just in
what the source material is I do like
that idea that okay every person in our
main cast is being named in a story and
thus that story is gonna come yet
directly for them and so in that way it
almost takes the final destination and
crashes it into goosebumps
yes sense yeah we've done it we've
linked it final destination meets
goosebumps but I love me the Creepshow
meets hope meets gamal Deltora oh yeah
and this trailer actually gave me that
the first one didn't as much is how
menacing and how truly chilling a lot of
this looks because in the book
part of what drove those homes so well
is the illustrations are so unsettling
and especially the creature designs here
being so faithful really do look like
they're ripped out of those pages and so
this I'm excited for this because it
looks like a more youth accessible
horror movie but that isn't pandering
that looks like it could still be
legitimately chilling no matter who you
are exactly yeah exactly because I feel
like even if this movie isn't ultimately
scary I feel like there will be some
like creepy moments or oh that's kind of
eerie no matter what but even if I don't
walk out going yeah I was scared if I if
I don't feel that way it seems like no
matter what it's gonna be like a lot of
fun and that level of funhouse horror
looks really like really striking here
I'm looking forward to it the lighting
with it I think is great because looks
like whenever there's a creature on
screen they really and like they go
full-blown with a specific color a lot
of it seems to be like dark blue or you
see one shot on the hallway where it's
full-blown red and but then you know
there's a little bit more naturalistic
lighting when you're just with the
characters but you're not with a
creature in there because I it's
interesting what you're saying to me
about how and the books this looks very
accurate to them because to me this
looks so much like Jeremiah del Toro's
makeup team designs yeah I mean there's
definitely a sense for that especially
in the later aspects when you get the
more contortion heavy creatures but at
least like the Scarecrow is like the
spitting image um the I forget her name
is but the woman in the red hallway is
like the spitting image of that
illustration and that's really
impressive to me because those
illustrations are so kind of not
impressionistic but they're not exactly
photo real either you know I hope this
film gets more promos or I hope it gets
more attention because right now it like
seems like people who watch these
trailers are very excited for it but it
doesn't seem like anyone like the
trailers don't perform as well as they
could be but I don't really hear too
much talk about this movie maybe because
of the fact there's some CBS studio
films and Lionsgate Co produces it so
it's essentially a little bit of a
smaller kind of movie but this looks
different
the
looks like it give me something really
special and I don't want to have just be
some cult hit that just comes and goes I
like a movie like this to really get a
lot of attention you know yeah so - and
I mean I'm excited yeah and I'm excited
for overall because the only I mean the
only movie of his I've seen as far as a
found footage or a mockumentary style
movie so to see what he's gonna do with
just a you know normal style unitive
cinematography I love the look of the
shots and stuff in here yeah and the
music in this trailer is also great yeah
don't don't like that I love that like
suspenseful build and I music and it's
not like relying on like eerie string
music which I feel like a lot of horror
movies do now like the eerie strings and
this wasn't doing that it was like very
heavy and something's coming something's
coming you know that was great mm-hmm
I'm excited for this I like these sort
of contained within town stories that we
get where you can really feel the
presence of the town doesn't say way
year this takes place in late sixties
late sixties yeah oh yeah I should have
been able to pick up all that by the way
some people are dressed yeah it could
look like the 50s - either way I like
them when you can really feel the kind
of town that we're living and I I don't
know if this is gonna be like some type
of as it's called Mill Valley but it's
gonna be something more like dairy from
it we're like oh the parents did
everyone have heard about these kind of
things before you know I'm wondering
what the the world of it is what's it
gonna be because it's kid focused and it
seems like the cop like yeah I know
about this author whatever well yeah and
I was wondering if that scene was gonna
progress to him being like oh this is
just a ghost story or or if maybe
there's something where it's like oh
yeah I've had an experience like this
before yeah yeah and that could actually
be a neat thing that'd be cool to have
some type of different twist on it but
you know like one of my complaints about
bright burn was not being able to know
the town or feel the town when all the
crazy shits going down and it really
seems like that you know with you have
your main ensemble and then you have
like other kids we're gonna get killed
off like douchebags for beating up a
scarecrow you know or a girl with a
pimple like characters who were just
gonna suffer never gonna cut around -
but I'm hoping that within that we
really do get a sense of even the parent
here because that's something I've
always liked in these kind of horror
movies as well any whom are you guys
excited for scary stories to tell in the
dark the sequel to goosebumps cuz sequel
to Tales from the Crypt comment below if
you liked this video please go ahead and
hit that like button also check us on
patreon last but not least speaking of
patreon patron of the day shout out to a
lovely man named Eric Mitchell hey buddy
I used to tell scary stories about a man
who used to be a lyft or uber driver and
he would go pick up people kill them and
then he got a job as at a tech company
and then one day at his tech office he
would snap he would go crazy he would
fall in love with a girl who wouldn't
love him back so he'd come to work and
kill everyone and I named him Derek
Mitchell if you guys work with Derek
Mitchell be aware be very aware you know
maybe give him like a some candy or
something just to let him know that
you're you're cool I think we're both
thinking of the Dane Cook journey for
both the Dane Cook joke
[Laughter]